Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde :
"la laïcité menacée".
La laïcité est une marque
de fabrique
culturelle et démocratique
spécifiquement française.
Si la France s'est constituée
de plusieurs France
cousues ensemble,
le vivre-ensemble
a pour langage commun,
depuis la Révolution française,
et, plus précisément,
depuis la loi de 1905,
cette fameuse laïcité.
Depuis, de nombreuses
adaptations ont vu le jour
et elles sont rendues
nécessaires
parce que l'islam politique,
entre autres oppositions,
et pour de pas parler
de l'islamo-gauchisme,
conteste les institutions
et les valeurs républicaines.
Dernier épisode en date :
Gabriel Attal,
ministre
de l'Education nationale,
a décidé d'interdire
dans nos écoles
le port de l'abaya
pour les femmes
et le qamis pour les hommes.
Cela rappelle
l'affaire du voile,
les fameux foulards à Creil,
en 89,
et pour suivre,
la loi de 2004
faisant interdiction de porter
des signes religieux
ostentatoires à l'école.
Nous évoquerons,
bien entendu,
comment s'articule
aujourd'hui
la laïcité
au sein de l'éducation
et les tensions engendrées.
Nous ferons aussi
une contextualisation
de cette laïcité,
malmenée au regard
d'une société française
où se développent
les communautarismes,
les radicalismes,
les particularismes
identitaires,
la violence des jeunes,
le wokisme de toutes sortes
de minorités agissantes,
la montée
des partis extrémistes,
et ce que Laurent Bouvet
nommait
"l'insécurité culturelle".
Vous êtes conviés,
chers invités,
à un véritable challenge
pour ausculter
ce désenchantement de la laïcité.
Je vais vous présenter.
Frédéric Salat-Baroux,
vous êtes avocat,
ancien secrétaire général
à la présidence
de la République.
Vincent Peillon,
vous êtes ancien ministre
de l'Education nationale
et actuellement
à la Cour des comptes.
Catherine Kintzler,
vous êtes philosophe,
universitaire
et spécialiste de la laïcité.
Houria Abdelouahed,
vous êtes psychanalyste,
professeure des universités,
et en visioconférence
depuis Jérusalem,
Michel Gurfinkiel,
ancien rédacteur en chef
de Valeurs actuelles
et actuel éditorialiste
au New York Sun.
Alors, une question,
d'emblée,
sur l'actualité brûlante.
Les meurtres des enseignants,
Samuel Paty,
il y a trois ans,
et récemment,
de Dominique Bernard,
interviennent dans un contexte
de djihadisme d'atmosphère,
selon Gilles Kepel.
Qu'en pensez-vous,
Vincent Peillon ?
-Je pense d'abord que...
On vit des drames en France
que nous n'avions pas vécu
depuis longtemps
dans l'Education nationale,
mais, vous vous en souvenez,
aussi ailleurs,
qu'un certain nombre
de nos concitoyens,
en fonction de leurs liens,
soit à l'école,
- quand on attaque l'école,
on attaque une idée
de la République -,
mais aussi en fonction
de leur confession juive.
Souvenons-nous des attentats
avec des enfants français,
juifs,
tués dans une école.
Nous vivons un moment
que nous n'avions pas vécu
depuis longtemps
et dont la dimension tragique,
on la voit quand on se parle,
elle ne doit pas être
sous-estimée
car nous avions oublié...
pourquoi,
ces quelques décennies,
que l'histoire est tragique.
Après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale,
la guerre a eu lieu,
on a reconstruit
une unité nationale,
le gaullo-communisme,
la laïcité
qui n'était pas contestée
et beaucoup de principes
qu'avaient en commun
la gauche et la droite
françaises.
Ce temps est en train
de passer, nous sommes
dans un moment où quelque chose
s'en va, quelque chose naîtra,
et nous sommes
dans l'entre-deux.
Cet entre-deux est violent,
tragique,
parfois répugnant.
Les enseignants aujourd'hui
sont extrêmement atteints,
tous,
par ce qu'il s'est passé,
deux fois, et je crois
qu'on doit faire preuve, là,
d'unité nationale
autour de ce sujet,
pas chercher non plus
à l'instrumentaliser trop,
mais réfléchir
comment nous pouvons,
effectivement,
avec la force de l'Etat,
avec l'intelligence
de la République,
éviter que cela se produise
et que cela gangrène,
car ça peut gangréner
de plein de points de vue.
-Merci.
Vous partagez cette position,
Frédéric Salat-Baroux ?
-Bien sûr, je pense que...
le fait que ces actes
inqualifiables
se passent à l'école
n'est pas le fruit du hasard.
Pour des minorités agissantes,
l'école,
c'est le coeur des valeurs
de la République
et le fait que ça soit
des professeurs
qui sont attaqués,
c'est le symbole...
Evidemment, la culture
est absolument essentielle,
et donc, derrière ça,
il y a une remise en cause
des valeurs de la République,
et une remise en cause
plus large des valeurs
occidentales, et donc,
ça veut dire que face à ça,
il faut à la fois
beaucoup de respect
et beaucoup de fermeté,
car ce qui est en jeu
est fondamental.
-Catherine Kintzler ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
Je partage cette analyse.
Il faut...
Je voudrais simplement rappeler
qu'en 2015, dès 2015,
l'Etat islamique
avait publié un appel
pour tuer des professeurs,
particulièrement en France,
donc, avant l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty.
Je pense que l'intégrisme
religieux,
et le totalitarisme
en général,
ne détestent rien
tant que l'école
et la laïcité,
parce que la laïcité,
c'est le contraire
de l'intégrisme.
Rappelons
que le principe de laïcité
ne s'applique pas
à tout le monde.
Il y a une dualité
du régime laïque.
Dans la société civile,
tout le monde peut afficher
des appartenances,
dans le cadre
du droit commun.
Ca s'applique...
Le principe de laïcité
s'applique
à un domaine précis,
délimité, à savoir
la puissance publique
et l'école, bien entendu,
avec certaines nuances.
Ils ne détestent rien
tant que l'école.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que l'école est le lieu,
en principe,
de la transmission du savoir.
Le savoir,
il n'y a pas d'autre autorité
que le savoir pour le savoir.
Il est immanent à lui-même,
comme l'association politique
républicaine
qui ne s'autorise
que d'elle-même.
-Le savoir, c'est la liberté.
-Et c'est émancipateur.
Voilà.
-Houria Abdelouahed ?
-Le savoir, c'est la liberté,
et puis, je pense
à Hannah Arendt :
pas de pensée sans liberté.
Et donc,
par rapport à Samuel Paty,
moi, le lendemain,
j'avais un cours d'anthropologie
à des étudiants à Paris VII
à l'époque,
j'étais à Paris VII,
et j'étais extrêmement affectée.
D'abord,
c'était l'assassinat
d'un collègue, d'un être humain,
c'est un acte barbare
et moi-même, je suis enseignante
et je travaille
sur des sujets très houleux
et donc, je me suis dit :
"Comment aborder les choses
avec mes étudiants ?"
On était arrivés à Durkheim
et là, je me suis dit :
"Pour parler de la religion
comme fait social,
"je vais introduire
Ibn Khaldoun."
Et là, je vous assure,
les étudiants
étaient aux anges
de découvrir
qu'il y avait aussi
des penseurs qui n'avaient
rien à voir avec ces...
effectivement,
ces gens qui sont
pour une pensée fanatique,
qui sont en train
d'assassiner le savoir.
Mais ce qui est...
Ce que je trouve
intéressant, là,
c'est qu'on aborde
la question de la laïcité
et tout de suite,
il y a ce qui interroge
la laïcité,
c'est-à-dire l'islam fanatique.
-Oui...
Alors, on va avoir l'avis
de Michel Gurfinkiel,
sur ce point.
Le journaliste que vous êtes
observe quoi ?
*-J'observe que...
En effet, jamais,
peut-être,
depuis très longtemps,
la laïcité
n'a été d'actualité politique
en France.
Je m'explique.
Je ne...
Je suis très méfiant
vis-à-vis des concepts.
Je crois que c'est
un défaut français
de confondre
les mots et les choses,
et plus exactement,
de dissimuler les choses
derrière les mots.
Si nous essayons de voir
historiquement,
sociologiquement,
ce que c'est que la démocratie,
on est tentés de dire
que la démocratie,
c'est un moyen
d'éviter la guerre civile.
Selon la formule célèbre
de Kipling,
il n'y a que deux manières
de gouverner :
casser les têtes
ou les compter.
Et je crois
que la laïcité,
historiquement,
ça servait à éviter
les guerres de religion
ou à mettre fin
aux guerres de religion.
C'est ça, le véritable fondement
de l'attitude laïque
dans les sociétés occidentales
et peut-être dans d'autres
sociétés occidentales.
La laïcité, à mon sens,
ne naît pas
avec la Révolution française,
ni même avec la Révolution
américaine,
qui est légèrement antérieure.
Elle naît avec les traités
de Westphalie,
qui introduisent
un concept révolutionnaire,
c'est que chaque Etat
de la chrétienté, en réalité,
a le droit d'avoir
sa propre religion.
A partir de ce moment,
on désacralise l'Etat
et on ouvre
un espace nouveau qui rend,
au sein d'un Etat,
d'une façon ou d'une autre,
possible une coexistence
entre plusieurs formes de religion,
ou en tout cas dans la communauté
des Etats européens,
qui rend possible cela.
-Merci.
Alors, Catherine Kintzler,
restons
dans l'actualité.
La Constitution en France
fait l'objet de beaucoup
de toilettage.
C'est pareil pour la laïcité.
Est-ce que vous pensez
que face à ce qu'on appelle
l'islamo-gauchisme,
est-ce que ça provoque
ce que Jean-Pierre Le Goff
appelle
une société malade de la peur
et qui engendre
une laïcité autocensurée ?
Evidemment, cela pose la question
de tous ces professeurs
qui s'autocensurent.
Les sondages sont effrayants.
-D'abord, je voudrais rappeler
que cette origine historique
qui vient d'être évoquée,
moi j'y introduirais
quand même une nuance,
c'est que la laïcité,
à la différence de la tolérance,
ne juxtapose pas les religions
et les communautés.
C'est déjà un progrès,
mais elle instaure un espace zéro.
Les Français comptent à partir
de 0 et pas à partir de 1.
C'est un collègue
qui m'a suggéré cette comparaison
avec la numération.
Un espace zéro,
ce n'est pas
un éventail d'appartenances
qui pourraient éventuellement
cohabiter,
mais ça rend possibles
les différentes appartenances
et aussi la non-appartenance.
La non-appartenance
est une condition.
Je voulais quand même revenir
sur ce point
parce que c'est à partir
de la Révolution française
que ça commence,
avec le mariage civil, etc.
Alors pour aborder
votre question, oui.
C'est pas une laïcité
autocensurée.
C'est une autocensure qui évite
les problèmes, tout simplement.
Les professeurs sont confrontés
à des intrusions, il faut dire,
des intrusions de toute sorte,
qu'au fond, une série
de dispositions réglementaires
sur l'école qui ont introduit
les associations,
qui ont donné
beaucoup de pouvoir aux parents
et les professeurs sont confrontés
à toutes sortes de...
C'est ce que j'appelle renvoyer
l'école à son extérieur.
L'école est constamment
confrontée à des demandes sociales,
comme si elle devait les satisfaire
et y répondre.
-Elle doit s'adapter
à la modernité.
-Alors que le coeur du métier,
c'est l'instruction, le savoir,
ce sont
des dispositifs centraux
qui permettent de faire face
aux différentes évolutions.
-C'est ce que vous avez vu ?
On vous a entendue.
-Les professeurs sont
les coupables idéaux
quand ça ne marche pas.
-Vincent Peillon,
vous avez été ministre
et vous êtes enseignant,
vous avez également
fait de l'enseignement.
Les profs font peur,
comme dit Obin ?
-C'était également le cas
à votre époque ?
-Pour faire un peu avancer le sujet,
je voudrais lancer
quelques idées comme ça.
D'abord, il ne faut pas
avoir une fausse conception,
celle des ignorants,
sur la laïcité.
Sachez, mon cher
Emile, que jusqu'en 1923,
il y a les devoirs envers Dieu
dans les instructions officielles
de la France,
on n'a pas arraché les crucifix
des écoles,
on s'est accommodés.
Ceux qui ont fait
la grande loi libérale de 195
n'étaient pas anti-religieux,
ce n'étaient pas
des laïcards
comme on l'a dit.
Si déjà on évitait ces sottises,
on verrait
que la laïcité, qui doit reposer
sur l'assentiment intérieur,
pourrait séduire plus,
à mon avis, de jeunes gens.
Ensuite,
vous avez parlé de l'islam
et immédiatement,
l'islamo-gauchisme...
C'est les listes maccarthystes
que j'ai vues
comme directeur de recherche au CNRS
circuler à nouveau.
C'est pas joli la dénonciation,
et mon histoire personnelle fait
que je ne l'aime pas.
J'ai été ministre,
vous l'avez rappelé,
mais j'ai été confronté
au problème de l'islam
radical et politique,
mais aussi,
lorsque j'ai voulu introduire,
parce que nous sommes un pays
où il n'y a pas
de femmes ingénieures,
pas de femmes scientifiques,
une lutte contre les stéréotypes
de genre...
Là, on est sur les contenus
de savoir.
C'est pas l'islam,
j'en avais un peu, radical,
que j'avais en face de moi,
c'est aussi des catholiques
d'une violence sans limites
et qui ont fait
reculer le gouvernement,
car je rappelle,
le dispositif égalité filles-garçons
a été supprimé en 2015
après mon départ.
ils n'ont pas tenu
sur quelque chose
qui concernait les savoirs
et j'entends
tous les mêmes qui l'ont supprimé
dire qu'il y a un problème
d'égalité filles-garçons
dans l'école française,
donc il faut complexifier
notre point de vue
si on ne veut pas commettre
des erreurs.
Mon plus grand souci lorsque
j'ai à la fois relancé
l'enseignement
que j'avais appelé morale laïque,
et en même temps affiché
la charte de la laïcité
dans tous les établissements
de France,
ce qui me souciait,
c'est que beaucoup de Français,
qui n'avaient pas
la même histoire
que la mienne,
voyaient la République et la laïcité
comme quelque chose
qui était
leur adversaire,
mais quand on leur parlait de ça,
une oppression possible,
une domination possible.
Et je finis juste là-dessus,
comme la laïcité intérieure,
telle que je la vois,
c'est être capable de douter aussi
de ses propres assurances...
C'est cartésien.
Je me suis demandé
s'il ne fallait pas
faire autrement,
parce qu'il faut les faire
venir à cette laïcité.
Nous voyons bien,
moi je pense comme vous,
qu'il y a deux dangers
pour la laïcité.
Le danger, je dirais,
de toutes les intolérances,
des extrémismes,
mais le danger des gens
qui croient être des laïques,
comme Ferdinand Buisson,
qui a fait l'établissement
de la République,
en France, mais qui sont
des nouveaux inquisiteurs,
créent une nouvelle orthodoxie,
et ne sont pas dans cette pensée
interrogative et inclusive
qu'est la laïcité.
-Une précision :
pourquoi l'enseignement
des faits religieux
n'a pas fonctionné ?
Vous étiez ministre,
est-ce qu'on pouvait pas...
-C'est une très belle idée,
je dois vous dire,
mais qui dans notre pays,
d'abord n'a pas été compris
d'un certain nombre de gens
qui pensent être laïques
en combattant le fait religieux.
Ensuite, nous avons un problème
de formation des enseignants
sur ce sujet,
qui ne s'en sont pas saisis.
Si vous prenez l'histoire
de l'école républicaine,
très souvent,
et c'est le cas d'ailleurs
de la morale laïque,
elle a été voulue,
on pourrait en faire l'histoire,
mais la laïcité est plus complexe,
mais ça n'a pas marché,
on n'a pas su l'enseigner.
Ce qui est facile à enseigner,
c'est l'instruction civique :
ça, ça s'apprend.
-Un marxiste ou un libéral
peut enseigner
l'économie...
On aurait pu enseigner
les faits religieux
sans appartenance...
-Sur l'économie,
il y a d'énormes polémiques
sur l'enseignement
des sciences économiques.
-Ecoutez...
-Le fait religieux,
c'est une difficulté.
-Alors, dans l'actualité,
Frédéric Salat-Baroux,
monsieur Attal,
ministre de l'Education nationale,
a interdit l'abaya
et le qamis.
Est-ce que ça n'allait pas de soi,
si on se réfère à la loi
de 2004,
à laquelle vous étiez associé,
à l'époque de la présidence Chirac ?
-Oui, bien sûr,
c'est l'application
de la loi de 2004,
mais je voudrais revenir...
Le problème,
c'est qu'on plonge laïcité,
interdit
et interdit contre l'islam.
C'est pas ça du tout, la laïcité.
Ca préexiste à la Révolution,
mais c'est une loi de liberté,
la liberté de croire
ou de ne pas croire
sans contrainte
et sans pression.
La laïcité,
le problème,
c'est qu'elle n'est pas comprise,
pas enseignée.
On n'est pas formé à la laïcité.
La laïcité n'est contre personne.
Prenons des exemples.
L'interdiction du voile à l'école...
On parle du voile à l'école,
mais c'est également
l'interdiction des kippas
pour les juifs.
Le voile n'est pas
une obligation religieuse,
la kippa en est une.
Donc, ça concerne
toutes les religions.
Prenons le catholicisme,
qui reste
la religion majoritaire en France,
quand on interdit les crèches
dans les mairies
ou, par exemple dans le Morbihan,
la statue de Jean-Paul II
surmonté d'une croix,
c'est le même principe.
Aucune des religions
ne se retrouve...
-On a des traditions,
Frédéric Salat-Baroux.
-La laïcité,
c'est le fait de préserver
l'espace public,
ce n'est pas
contre l'islam, ce n'est pas
des principes de contraintes...
-On est bien d'accord...
-Ca permet à chacun de vivre
dans la liberté.
Pour revenir à l'abaya...
Je crois
que c'est important de partir de ça.
Il faut d'abord expliquer
ce qu'est la laïcité,
et ce n'est pas
n'importe quel principe.
L'article premier
de notre Constitution dit :
"La France est une République
indivisible, laïque, démocratique
"et sociale."
Le "laïque" vient en deuxième.
C'est un principe fondamental.
Pour revenir à l'abaya,
quand on regarde les motifs
de la loi de 2004,
il est dit :
"Tous les signes
"ou tenues ostensibles
sont interdits,
"c'est-à-dire ceux
"qui font reconnaître
"la personne qui les porte
en fonction de sa religion."
-Vous parlez
de neutralité,
mais quand on se promène en France,
dans les villages,
dans les grandes villes,
c'est ponctué
d'églises partout.
On en trouve partout.
Les vacances scolaires
ont lieu à...
Bon, donc...
Doit-on faire fi
des traditions religieuses
d'un pays ?
-La laïcité,
ce n'est pas contre les religions,
c'est un cadre qui permet
à chacune des religions...
De ceux qui croient ou pas
de s'exprimer.
C'est certainement pas,
on va pas être à rebours des choses,
un instrument pour privilégier
la tradition chrétienne de la France
par rapport à d'autres traditions
d'autres religions.
C'est un cadre
qui est profondément moderne,
sauf qu'aujourd'hui,
il n'est ni expliqué
ni défendu.
-Houria Abdelouahed ?
-Alors, moi,
j'écoute, et c'est vrai
que c'est un débat houleux
et passionnant en même temps...
Enfin, les croyances,
ça m'a fait penser
à cette superbe phrase
d'André Miquel
que j'aime beaucoup :
"Croire ou rêver."
Donc, effectivement,
la laïcité ne convoque pas
l'obligation d'une croyance,
chrétienne ou autre,
c'est la liberté offerte à chacun
de croire ou de ne pas croire,
sans vraiment
que le "ne pas croire"
entraîne des répressions,
comme dans certains pays,
décapitations ou autre.
Alors, par rapport
à cette histoire de abaya...
Moi, je le prononce à l'arabe.
Il y a deux questions
qui me viennent :
je m'interroge d'abord
sur la régression du féminisme
en France.
Comment se fait-il...
Moi étudiante,
la abaya n'existait pas,
le voile non plus,
le burkini n'existait pas,
et la question religieuse
n'existait pas.
Ce qui faisait
l'union ou la relation
entre les étudiants,
là je parle
de mon passé d'étudiante,
c'était être passionné
par le cinéma,
par la psychanalyse,
par la littérature,
des choses qui faisaient lien,
pas qui séparaient.
Donc, d'abord, la régression
du féminisme en France.
Deuxièmement, la abaya,
j'ai beaucoup écrit là-dessus,
d'abord n'existe pas dans le Coran,
et donc, quand Onfray dit
"c'est un fait civilisationnel",
pas du tout.
Et donc,
là, je dirais,
en tant que psychanalyste,
parce que ça concerne quand même
les adolescentes...
Donc, aussi...
Quelle est cette attitude,
en lien avec le corps,
sachant que le corps est lié
au pulsionnel,
à la sexualité,
à la question libidinale,
la question de la honte
de montrer mon corps, etc.
C'est une façon
qui, en même temps, consiste
à cacher et à montrer.
Donc, lié aussi à certaines...
Quelque chose qui est en train de...
De venir au-devant de la scène
sans qu'on sache ce que c'est,
c'est la question
de l'identité religieuse,
et c'est là
où il y a problème.
Ca veut dire quoi,
"une identité religieuse",
sachant que l'identité,
c'est un processus,
c'est une fabrique,
elle est en marche ?
La question de la abaya,
elle englobe une complexité
qui n'est pas réduite
à quelque chose qu'on appelle
"fait civilisationnel".
-Alors, écoutez...
-Ce n'est pas civilisationnel.
-Je voudrais
qu'on sorte de la théorie
et qu'on rentre dans ce qui existe,
pardonnez-moi.
Si la communauté musulmane de France
s'inscrit pour l'essentiel
dans le vivre-ensemble,
on observe,
parmi la jeunesse
qui en est issue,
à la fois une haine
anti-française
et de l'antisémitisme.
Catherine Kintzler ?
-Ecoutez, je vais quand même réagir
à ce que je viens d'entendre,
qui est très riche.
Ce n'est pas sans rapport
avec votre question.
Il me semble que ce qui est ciblé,
ce sont des tests
à partir d'incompréhensions
ou d'incompréhensions entretenues,
la laïcité comme interdiction, etc.
Non.
Je voudrais rappeler
ce que j'appelle
"la respiration laïque" :
nous avons 2 domaines,
la société civile,
où on affiche
ses appartenances, et le domaine
de l'autorité publique,
où on les suspend.
C'est une respiration.
L'école offre une double vie.
-Oui, mais ça,
on est bien d'accord,
mais on observe...
-C'est cette double vie
qui est récusée par l'intégrisme,
car il veut
que la vie soit uniforme,
qu'elle soit la même partout.
J'ai coécrit
avec Elisabeth Badinter,
Alain Finkielkraut, Régis Debray
et Elisabeth de Fontenay,
en 1989, le fameux appel
"profs, ne capitulons pas".
C'était une déclaration
d'anti-intégrisme,
cette déclaration-là :
"Si vous permettez
"l'intrusion
"de tous les affichages
des identités..."
On dirait aujourd'hui
qu'ils se signalent
par des tags, qui sont...
On construit son identité
comme une pizza
avec des ingrédients disponibles.
Ce n'est pas comme ça
qu'on la construit.
On se cherche, on doute.
Si vous autorisez cela,
vous donnez raison
à ceux qui disent par exemple
aux jeunes filles voilées :
"Tu dois te voiler partout,
tout le temps."
C'est comme ça
que je vois les choses.
Donc, si nous avons aujourd'hui
cette vague d'intégrisme,
eh bien, c'est précisément
cette...
Cette tendance à vouloir installer
la même loi partout.
"Il n'y a qu'une parole,
"qu'une tendance,
"et tous ceux qui s'y opposent
doivent être éliminés."
Eliminés politiquement,
idéologiquement,
physiquement,
nous le voyons.
Voilà.
-Merci. Michel Gurfinkiel,
comment vous voyez,
puisque vous voyagez beaucoup,
cette montée de l'antisémitisme
et de l'anti-France
dans les banlieues françaises ?
-Je me bornerai à dire
que c'est un fait sociologique.
C'est un fait sociologique.
On peut l'expliquer
de 1001 manières.
Il y a les idées abstraites
et il y a, à côté,
la culture
en tant que bouillon de culture,
en tant que condensation de...
De tous les mythes,
de toutes les pulsions
qui ont pu exister
dans l'histoire humaine.
Le bouillon de culture
ne s'éteint jamais.
Est-ce que les idées
que je qualifie d'"abstraites"
parce qu'elles sont raisonnées,
ont le moyen de discipliner
le bouillon de culture ?
C'est le point essentiel.
N'avions-nous pas
une certaine pratique
qui nous permettait de le faire
jusqu'à, peut-être,
une génération de nous ?
N'avons-nous pas perdu
cette pratique ?
Cette pratique suppose bien entendu
de l'autorité.
Elle suppose de la verticalité.
Elle suppose de la souveraineté.
Elle suppose que l'Etat dise,
à un moment ou un autre,
"eh bien, voilà comment
je veux que les choses existent",
et que l'Etat travaille à constituer
un consensus
autour de cette décision.
-L'autorité politique est remise
en question, n'est-ce pas ?
-Toutes les autorités
sont remises en question.
Pour aller dans le sens...
Il y a un nouveau féminisme.
Ne le négligez pas.
Il est plus radical
que celui qu'ont connu
ma génération et la vôtre.
Le féminisme n'a pas disparu.
Beaucoup s'en inquiètent
dans les universités et ailleurs.
-Il n'a pas disparu, excusez-moi,
il y a quelques années, le burkini,
ces choses n'existaient pas.
-Elles n'existaient pas
dans le regard
de ceux qui commentent.
Quand vous dirigez une nation,
vous devez faire vivre
tout le monde ensemble.
Dans cette rentrée scolaire,
il manque plusieurs milliers
de professeurs.
Plusieurs milliers d'élèves
n'ont pas d'inscription.
Il faut des professeurs.
M. Attal interdit,
et très bien, l'abaya.
Je l'ai rencontré,
il l'a rendu public.
Combien de cas,
sur 12 millions d'élèves ? 200.
Si on regarde dans les journaux
le traitement de ces 200 cas,
qu'il fallait peut-être traiter,
certes,
par rapport au traitement
de l'absence de professeurs,
d'inscription pour nos élèves,
c'est scandaleux.
Quand on veut gérer un pays
au nom de l'intérêt général
et d'une certaine idée de la France
liée à l'instruction
- nos instructions disent :
"L'école, en instruisant,
éduque à la liberté." -,
on se préoccupe autant
d'avoir des professeurs
que de la longueur du débat,
stigmatiser certains
et traiter que de ces problèmes.
Donc, il faut les traiter
avec fermeté,
mais il faut quand même mesurer
quel abaissement intellectuel c'est,
de ne pas se poser
les grandes questions
concernant nos professeurs,
leur recrutement,
leur présence à l'école,
leur remplacement,
etc., etc.,
et sans doute aussi
les disciplines que l'on enseigne.
-Vous êtes d'accord,
quand Gabriel Attal a dit
que les manquements
aux valeurs républicaines
excluent les élèves
qui s'en inspirent
et qui sont porteurs...
-Les élèves et...
et les adultes,
et les hommes politiques
qui se trouvent
dans des situations...
J'ai connu un président
qui considérait
que l'imam, le rabbin
valaient mieux
que le professeur pour enseigner.
Il faut aussi mesurer
que c'est pas à l'école de résoudre
tous les problèmes de la société :
la violence,
l'abaissement intellectuel,
et il ne faut pas chercher
des boucs émissaires,
il faut de l'autorité,
il faut rappeler ces choses.
La dernière chose que j'ai à dire...
-Pas trop long,
M. Peillon.
-Il y a - je l'ai vécu
comme professeur, à Nanterre,
dans ce lycée très difficile,
il y a déjà 30 ans -
qui a...
-On va parler, d'ailleurs,
de cette époque.
-Les grands récits...
Moi, je viens d'une famille
communiste. Communiste !
Beaucoup de juifs intellectuels
étaient communistes.
-J'ai été élevé par des gens
comme ça. Le socialisme
a fait rêver,
le gaullisme a tenu les gens,
mais il faut être réaliste :
ces grands récits
se sont effondrés.
Peut-être la promesse républicaine
n'a pas
été tenue, pour certains.
Peut-être
une histoire se redécouvre.
Nous avons ça à gérer.
Et une jeunesse,
sur notre territoire, à gérer.
C'est plus complexe
que des bouts de tissus,
200 personnes,
et la stigmatisation
d'une population.
C'est notre histoire nationale
qu'il faut réécrire ensemble,
en étant capables
de trouver une place à chacun.
-Michel Gurfinkiel ?
*-Oui, je...
Par rapport à ce que Vincent Peillon
vient de dire
sur son successeur,
Gabriel Attal.
Gabriel Attal, de toute évidence,
a procédé à son interdiction
de l'abaya parce qu'il savait,
au préalable
- il y a eu des sondages,
dans ce sens,
qui datent du mois de juin,
sauf erreur -
qu'il y avait une majorité
écrasante, écrasante, en France,
pour l'interdiction de ce signe
ostensible et ostentatoire,
non seulement d'une religion,
mais d'un fondamentalisme
et d'un extrémisme religieux.
Quand le ministre
de l'Education nationale
a effectivement pris cette décision,
qui, d'ailleurs,
se réduit à l'application de la loi
telle qu'elle existe,
nous avons, à nouveau,
pu mesurer
le soutien que celle-ci...
rencontrait dans l'opinion,
puisque, disons que le soutien
est allé de
- je cite de mémoire,
mais c'est très facile à vérifier -
de 90 %, à droite,
jusqu'à 79 %
chez les électeurs
socialistes.
-On voit... On le prendra après.
Frédéric Salat-Baroux.
-Je crois que la question
que vous posez,
- je prends le temps de répondre -
est fondamentale.
Je ne suis pas convaincu
- mais n'en débattons pas -
qu'il y a généralisation
du sentiment anti-France.
Mais, à supposer,
il y a deux terrains
sur lesquels on doit agir :
d'abord, la défense
du modèle français.
On prend deux secondes,
avec un peu de recul,
et c'est valable aussi
pour le wokisme,
mais dans quel pays,
quand un enfant naît,
il est pris en charge par l'Etat,
il a des aides immédiatement,
on peut accoucher gratuitement
dans un hôpital,
l'éducation est gratuite,
quand il y a
des accidents de la vie,
la société est là,
la vieillesse n'est plus synonyme
de misère,
qu'on soit riche
ou pauvre, quand on a un cancer,
on est soigné avec qualité,
mais il faut d'abord
que ça soit dit :
ce pays,
avant de lui cracher dessus,
il faut commencer
par lui dire merci.
C'est le premier point.
Ca, ça n'est pas
dans la parole politique.
La deuxième chose,
c'est l'autorité.
Il faut faire
un peu d'histoire.
Prenons la laïcité :
en 1905,
jusqu'en 1909,
le pape Pie X
prend une bulle, pour considérer
que la loi est inacceptable.
Des cardinaux disent :
"Il ne faut pas appliquer la loi,
"et les personnes
qui l'appliqueront,
"leurs enfants ne pourront pas
faire la première communion,
"dans un pays
qui a 90 % de catholiques,
"et on ne donnera pas
"les sacrements."
Qu'est-ce que fait l'Etat ?
L'Etat envoie des cardinaux,
des évêques,
des centaines de prêtres,
en application de l'article 31
de la loi de 1905,
devant le tribunal correctionnel,
et ils sont condamnés.
C'est aussi ça, l'autorité.
C'est pas la même période,
mais l'autorité,
que ce soit dans la sphère
de la société, ou à l'école,
doit s'imposer.
Il y a des règles.
On peut aujourd'hui poursuivre,
c'est l'article 433
du code pénal,
tout ce qui est menace
vis-à-vis de personne dépositaire
de l'autorité publique.
Donc, ce qui doit être fait,
c'est d'abord la défense
de notre modèle, et l'autorité...
Le professeur ne peut pas
tout faire. C'est à l'Etat
d'aider le professeur.
C'est le rapport
entre la justice,
la police et l'autorité,
qui doit rentrer,
de manière républicaine,
aussi,
dans l'école.
Mais les défis qu'on a
sont pas tellement plus lourds
à assumer que ceux
de 1909,
quand 90 % d'un pays
qui est catholique
et un pape qui dit :
"N'appliquez pas la loi", et
que les prélats le disent en chaire,
c'est dur,
et pourtant, la République
a fait face. Vous disiez que c'était
question d'autorité de l'Etat,
ça l'est fondamentalement,
dans ce qu'elle a de plus noble.
-Catherine Kintzler ?
-Merci d'avoir rappelé que, au fond,
c'est un acte unilatéral
de la puissance publique
qui s'impose, et nous avons besoin
de renouveler cet acte,
quels que soient...
devant les obstacles.
Je voulais simplement dire
qu'il faut instruire,
il faut recruter les professeurs,
sur haut niveau,
mais il faut leur donner
les conditions pour travailler,
la sérénité,
et ces obstacles,
ces tests auxquels ils font face,
et auxquels ils essaient
de répondre, les uns par évitement,
les autres parce que... en ayant
suivi ce fameux "pas de vagues",
et comment
le leur reprocher ?
Quand ils sont constamment
en butte à des critiques ?
Et...
plus que cela, même.
C'est une litote.
Donc, il faut
que cette autorité s'impose.
Je ne suis pas choquée
par ce traitement de l'abaya,
car ce sont les obstacles
qu'il faut traiter d'abord.
Il faut les lever.
Vous avez raison de rappeler
comment fonctionne
cette autorité.
Je voulais simplement dire...
J'ai dit que l'école doit
offrir une double vie
aux élèves.
Je suis fille d'immigrés.
Ma tante,
qui était d'origine italienne,
était contente de l'école.
C'était pas une élève extraordinaire
mais elle sentait
qu'elle était traitée,
à l'école, pour elle-même,
qu'on levait
toute autre considération
sur ce qu'elle était,
sur son origine, etc.
Je me rappelle
une très belle parole
du rabbin Delphine Horvilleur,
qui a dit,
au micro
d'une radio publique,
- je crois que c'était
en 2018 - :
"La promesse républicaine
qui nous a été faite,
"c'est que chacun puisse
se développer lui-même
"à la première personne
"du singulier."
Et ça, c'est ce genre de choses
qu'il faut rappeler aussi
avec toutes
les dispositions républicaines,
et nous ne le faisons pas assez.
Il y a
une autoflagellation,
une mode depuis longtemps,
mais il faut arrêter.
Il faut arrêter.
-Houria Abdelouahed,
sur l'autorité ?
-Je suis professeure,
donc, je ne peux vraiment aller
que dans ce sens-là,
et donner des exemples,
puisque, tout à l'heure, tu nous as
invités à donner des exemples.
Il nous arrive,
des fois, de faire face
à des discussions avec des étudiants
qui disent : "On ne veut pas
entendre le mot 'pulsion',
"parce que ça heurte
notre religion."
On se trouve là vraiment porteurs,
on va dire,
des connaissances, d'un savoir,
et comme professeur
on est psychanalyste,
psychologue,
donc on a affaire
à des expressions
de la pulsion
et ses avatars,
comme disait Freud,
et des fois, comme je disais,
je tombe des nues,
parce que,
vraiment, c'est des discours
qui commencent
à revenir,
mais de façon assez massive,
et à nous menacer.
Alors,
en ce qui me concerne,
j'ai écrit beaucoup...
comme ça,
sur la question
du déshéritage dans l'islam,
la question du foulard,
la question de... Etc.
Je me pose,
jusqu'à présent,
la question,
parce que, effectivement,
il y a un islam radical, fanatique,
qui est extrêmement
dangereux,
qui menace non seulement
le vivre-ensemble,
mais nous aussi,
qui menace
les pays arabes, etc.
Et ce qui, vraiment,
me chagrine,
c'est que cet islam fanatique,
radical, abject,
il met à l'arrière,
aussi,
tous les autres aspects
de la culture arabe
et aussi tous les aspects
de l'islam.
Pour avoir traduit le diwan
de la poésie arabe classique,
je vois que la poésie,
c'est une chose,
que la philosophie,
la mystique, c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire,
et on arrive devant quelque chose
d'ultra, même pas conservateur,
il faut trouver
vraiment un autre mot,
un wahhabisme qui nous tue,
nous aussi,
et c'est celui-là qui s'impose.
Et la question...
-Pas trop long,
parce que le temps avance
et on a des questions.
-C'est important. Je reviens
à la question adolescente,
avec l'abaya.
Comment se fait-il que ces jeunes,
qui ne connaissent
pas l'arabe,
qui ne peuvent pas lire le Coran,
qui...
-Il y a
des influences extérieures.
-Oui, mais c'est des sujets,
il faudrait
complexifier,
des sujets
très importants.
-Michel Gurfinkiel ?
*-Je disais simplement,
en réponse aux observations
de... de notre ami Peillon
sur la décision
de Gabriel Attal
d'interdire l'abaya
à l'école,
que, visiblement,
le ministre avait tenu compte...
De l'opinion publique
avant de prendre sa décision,
puisqu'il y a eu
des sondages spécifiques...
-Vous l'aviez dit.
*-Voilà. Et que, par la suite,
quand il a pris sa décision,
cette décision a été
massivement appuyée
par l'opinion publique française,
y compris, par exemple,
chez les électeurs
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
qui sont censés être
les moins hostiles
à la place,
disons, de l'islam
dans la société française.
Je pense que le débat
sur la laïcité est faussé,
en réalité,
pour une raison
très simple.
-Pas trop long, cher Michel,
car on a peu de temps.
*-Les guerres de religions.
Les guerres de religions ne sont pas
des guerres sur un dogme,
elles sont des guerres
sur un mode de vie.
Ce qui a été fondamental,
par exemple, en France,
dans le vieux débat entre
l'Eglise catholique et les laïcs,
c'était pas une question de dogme,
c'était la question du divorce,
je crois que
le vrai problème
que nous avons devant nous,
ce n'est pas un problème
de compatibilité
de la religion islamique
avec le cadre républicain français,
c'est une question
de mode de vie.
Y a-t-il,
dans l'opinion française,
la perception que leur mode de vie
est en danger ?
Y a-t-il, dans d'autres milieux
de la société française, la volonté,
le projet d'imposer
un autre mode de vie ?
Voilà la véritable question.
-Une question politique
et idéologique,
qui nous concerne tous.
Le mouvement de mai 68
a été
un mouvement révolutionnaire.
Les émeutes
de juillet 2023,
"a" été une incandescence,
que certains
considèrent comme révolutionnaire,
et d'autres comme violente.
Est-ce que vous diriez,
parce que vous avez rappelé
que vous étiez
de famille communiste,
que le gauchisme culturel
des années 1968
a préparé
la violence
de l'islamo-gauchisme,
aujourd'hui ?
-Bon...
Les violences, on voit bien
que le ton même des débats,
quand on aborde ces questions,
c'est qu'on cherche la violence.
On ne cherche pas l'apaisement,
mais à désigner les ennemis.
C'est un moment de l'histoire.
On en parlera peut-être mieux
dans quelques décennies.
Pour ajouter une nouvelle idée
à notre débat,
mais qui était présente chez Jaurès,
chez Charles Renouvier,
chez Ferdinand Buisson,
le créateur du Parti socialiste,
la SFIO, le créateur
du Parti radical socialiste.
La gauche.
Ils sont aussi
les artisans
de la loi libérale
de 1905,
et souvent
des confessions minoritaires,
qui ont voulu...
-Pascal Ory
rappelle que l'antisémitisme
trouve ses sources
à l'extrême droite
et dans les franges
de l'extrême gauche.
-Ca a été le cas très tôt :
Proudhon, etc.
Mais on parle de Jaurès et Buisson,
même s'il y a des textes de Buisson
à relire de ce point de vue.
La question que je veux soulever,
c'est que, chez les artisans
de la laïcité française,
est bien de la loi de 1905,
la laïcité,
c'est un principe :
liberté
de conscience,
séparation des Eglises et de l'Etat,
c'est aussi, derrière,
une philosophie,
et cette philosophie,
elle s'accompagne d'une idée,
qui est
que la justice sociale,
l'égalité, fait partie
de ce qui est nécessaire,
pour développer cette instruction
chez chacun.
Il ne faut pas sous-estimer,
dans un pays où les fractures
et territoriales sont si puissantes,
et s'aggravent, que chez nous,
y compris dans l'école...
Je vais vous dire, M. Malet,
puisque vous êtes
si attentif à la laïcité :
600 000 élèves
en lycée professionnel,
le dernier gouvernement,
qui a gesticulé
de façon extraordinaire,
avec M. Blanquer, sur ça,
a supprimé l'histoire
et la culture générale
à ces jeunes,
venant plus de banlieues
que du 7e arrondissement,
où nous sommes.
Est-ce une bonne chose ?
Non.
Car je crois, comme cela a été dit,
qu'il faut enseigner
la République, la laïcité.
Mais on s'est dit :
"Ces gens-là, c'est pas la peine.
On retire des heures."
C'est grave.
Je ne suis pas contre
- pas de malentendu -
cette histoire d'abaya.
Je suis pour qu'on parle aussi
de toutes les autres questions,
et qu'on comprenne bien
que ne faire
que le débat agonistique
sur la laïcité
permet aussi
de ne pas parler de problèmes :
l'accroissement
des inégalités scolaires,
le décrochage d'instruction
de la France à l'international,
ça, ce sont
des sujets massifs,
et parlons de l'abaya,
200 jeunes filles, bien,
parlons du reste,
ou la France
va décrocher, elle le fait,
et c'est dommage.
-Frédéric Salat-Baroux ?
-Je pense que... Je suis tout à fait
d'accord, évidemment.
La question que vous posez,
c'est l'importance, dans ce débat,
de l'islamo-gauchisme.
Effectivement...
-On peut le sourcer, par rapport
au gauchisme radical ?
Jean-Pierre Le Goff dit
qu'il était teinté
de violence
et de nihilisme
dès ses sources.
-Oui, mais d'abord,
la différence
entre 2004 et aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'en 2004, il y avait pas
l'islamo-gauchisme,
et donc c'était un débat
qui n'était pas troublé
par cette intrusion par la gauche,
si tenté
que ça soit de la gauche,
l'islamo-gauchisme,
dans le débat sur la laïcité.
Et effectivement,
la question, aujourd'hui,
c'est la nature
de cet islamo-gauchisme
qui interroge
par rapport à la tradition
de gauche.
Il faut encore faire une pas
pour le comprendre, de la laïcité
jusqu'à tout ce débat,
qualifier de terrorisme ou pas,
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
en Israël.
Derrière ça, il y a
une question qui est,
au fond, les valeurs de la gauche,
et Vincent Peillon,
qui a écrit
un magnifique "Jaurès",
comprendra,
il y a la gauche
d'avant l'affaire Dreyfus
et la gauche d'après
l'affaire Dreyfus.
Avant l'affaire Dreyfus,
il y a une sorte de radicalité
qui fait qu'on juge une personne
en fonction de sa classe sociale.
Avec l'affaire Dreyfus,
la gauche dit :
"La question, c'est pas
de savoir où est Dreyfus
"et ce qu'il a fait,
"mais à partir du moment
où il est victime
"d'une injustice,
elle nous concerne tous",
et c'est le basculement
avec Jaurès de la gauche
idéologique,
qu'on pourrait qualifier
aujourd'hui de plus gauchiste
avec une base antisémite très forte,
vers une gauche humaniste.
Aujourd'hui, tout le problème
de l'islamo-gauchisme,
c'est cette régression
qui consiste à tout idéologiser
jusqu'à perdre
des choses fondamentales,
ce qui nous réunit
à travers la laïcité,
présenter cette valeur de liberté
comme une valeur, au fond,
d'interdiction,
d'asservissement
et d'aliénation,
et d'à nouveau juger
les personnes non en fonction
de ce qu'ils ont vécu
et des drames qu'ils ont vécu,
mais en fonction du positionnement
dans une logique très abstraite
et très idéologique.
Et ce combat-là, au même titre
qu'il faut avoir un combat
sur le terrain de la laïcité,
il faut avoir un combat
sur le terrain
de cet islamo-gauchisme,
et singulièrement,
des gens qui sont inscrits à gauche.
C'est un combat fondamental.
Nous, à droite, dans les années 80,
il a fallu assumer un combat
contre l'extrême droite.
C'est valable aujourd'hui...
-Frédéric Salat-Baroux,
quand des rives
des Insoumis,
on entend qualifier
et assigner
le CRIF,
le Conseil
représentatif des institutions
juives de France,
à l'extrême droite,
et qu'on décide que Fabien Roussel,
le leader communiste,
c'est Doriot,
est-ce que c'est la faillite
d'un certain discours laïque ?
-Peu importe,
c'est d'abord un terrain
de combat politique.
Ils sont en train
de retrouver...
Il faut toujours
faire de l'histoire.
Ils sont en train de retrouver
le jacobinisme de 1794,
c'est-à-dire, il faut des complots,
des coupables, des guillotines.
Mais ce combat-là,
il faut l'assumer.
Bien sûr qu'il faut remettre
les choses à leur place.
Le CRIF, on peut contester
tout ce qu'il peut dire,
mais ça, c'est un vrai débat.
Mais il est hors
de question, et c'est le problème
des Insoumis...
C'est que la réalité
n'est plus regardée en fonction
de ce qu'elle est
mais en fonction
d'une classification intellectuelle
qui fait qu'on en oublie
la personne. Et en arriver
à ne pas être capable de dire :
"Actes de terrorisme,
"actes de barbarie",
c'est montrer à quel point
cette dérive
est devenue dangereuse.
Et dans ces cas-là,
il faut la combattre sur le terrain
des principes,
et c'est d'abord un enjeu
pour la gauche,
la gauche jaurésienne.
-C'est un très vieux débat.
Je mets un mot pour donner
une clé de lecture
sur cette affaire Mélenchon
et l'affaire avant affaire Dreyfus.
Ce qui est insupportable aujourd'hui
dans l'attitude
de la France insoumise
et d'un certain nombre de gens
de la France insoumise,
c'est qu'ils confondent
la logique de justice,
qui veut dire qu'il y a un individu
et des choses
qu'on ne peut pas accepter,
et la logique de domination.
C'est comme la logique
de classes.
Ils se disent :
"Il y a des dominants, des dominés."
Et c'est l'excuse.
C'est la même chose
qu'on avait au 19e
et qu'on a en ce moment
depuis une quinzaine de jours.
Il y a des gens qui continuent
de penser qu'il y a des principes
universels de justice
qui valent moins que cette logique.
Cette gauche-là
ne s'en remettra pas
car notre pays ne l'acceptera pas
et que les électeurs de gauche,
majoritaires, ne l'accepteront pas.
Mais c'est le même débat,
c'est ce moment
où des principes moraux, universels,
libéraux au sens
des Droits de l'homme,
car le socialisme français
est libéral,
eh bien sont bafoués
par des logiques qui ne voient...
Elle existe,
la logique de domination.
Mais qui prend le pas.
-Vous qui connaissez
bien l'histoire,
à l'échelle humaine,
de Léon Blum,
quand on lui a reproché
de ne pas avoir envoyé
l'armée française
dans la guerre d'Espagne,
il a dit : "Le contexte
ne le permettait pas
"parce que mes amis étaient
de moins en moins socialistes
"et de plus en plus nationaux."
Catherine Kintzler.
-Je voudrais dire qu'en 2004,
effectivement,
ça n'apparaissait pas sous forme
d'islamo-gauchisme.
Je ne sais pas
si c'est toujours
sur le site parlementaire,
les débats de la commission Stasi,
les auditions.
Regardez l'évolution
des personnes
qui siégeaient
dans cette commission
et qui n'étaient pas toutes à droite
quand elles étaient contre
la loi de 2004.
Je remonte en 89.
C'est mon expérience.
Eh bien en 89,
il y en a
qui se sont amusés
à éplucher les noms,
et sur les consonances, dire :
"Ah, Kintzler, Finkielkraut,
"Badinter, tiens !"
Donc on avait quand même
une petite musique
qui se jouait là.
Et je pense aussi
à rappeler que nous nous sommes
faits traiter carrément
de fachos,
de fascistes.
Et il y avait beaucoup
de gens de gauche
dans cette position.
Notamment, je rappelle
que la fédération
de l'Education nationale
était tout à fait...
Nous l'avons trouvée
en face de nous.
Il faut rappeler ça.
Vincent Peillon
a raison de rappeler
la différence entre logique
de domination
et de justice, parce que la lecture
en termes de domination
permet tout
en termes
d'injustice.
-Merci.
Il nous reste deux minutes,
un mot, Houria Abdelouahed.
-Je rejoins tout à fait
votre point de vue.
Effectivement, il y a de plus
en plus de précarisation,
il y a de plus en plus de fissures
au niveau du tissu social.
J'apprends vraiment
que les étudiants,
que les élèves
de banlieue ou les élèves
du système professionnel
n'aient plus
de culture générale,
je suis scandalisée.
Il y a quelques années,
j'avais proposé,
parce que j'étais auditionnée
par le Parlement
sur la question de l'éducation.
Moi, je crois en l'éducation.
J'ai dit qu'il fallait
quand même enseigner par exemple
Avicenne,
Averroès, faire entrer des auteurs
Assia Djebar, Amine Maalouf
sur "Les identités meurtrières",
etc., et ça, vraiment,
ça contribuerait
à ce qu'on appelle
le vivre ensemble
aussi entre les étudiants
et les élèves.
-Merci. Peut-être
que vous serez entendue
par le ministère
de l'Education nationale.
-J'espère.
-Michel Gurfinkiel, un mot,
car l'horloge nous indique
qu'on est au terme
de l'émission.
-Un jour, un ami américain
m'a dit :
"Ce qui est formidable
avec la France,
"c'est que c'est l'éternel pays
de l'affaire Dreyfus."
Il voulait dire par-là que c'est
un pays où les querelles
sont ce qu'elles sont,
mais où les mobilisations
pour sortir de ces querelles
sont également ce qu'elles sont,
et c'est une singularité française,
qui, finalement,
nous honore
et nous permet d'espérer.
-Merci d'avoir terminé
sur ce mot d'espérance.
Je crois que René Char disait :
"Résistance n'est qu'espérance."
Les deux mots vont ensemble.
Il me reste à vous rappeler,
mais très rapidement,
une bibliographie :
Catherine Kintzler,
"Penser la laïcité",
c'est votre crédo ?
-C'est pas un crédo,
ce sont des principes.
C'est pas une religion civile,
c'est le contraire.
-On aurait pu en parler.
-Vous restez toujours...
-Oui, je ne renie rien
de ce qui a été écrit là-dedans.
-Très bien.
Je rappelle que Jean-Pierre Le Goff
vient de publier
"Mes années folles",
un itinéraire
intéressant, il a été quasiment
un casseur en mai 68,
et aujourd'hui,
il considère
que c'était
de la pure brutalité.
On en pensera ce qu'on veut,
mais c'est intéressant.
Frédéric Salat-Baroux,
on a déjà parlé de votre
"Blum le magnifique".
Vous pouvez dire un mot
sur ce que vous préparez ?
-C'est autre chose.
Je prépare un livre sur la bataille
de la Bérézina,
qui est l'occasion de réinterroger
le parcours de Napoléon,
notamment à l'aune des valeurs
de la Révolution
et puis de son vainqueur,
Alexandre Ier, aussi à découvrir.
-Houria Abdelouahed, on a déjà parlé
aussi de votre livre,
"Face à la destruction,
psychanalyse en temps de guerre."
Un mot pour nos téléspectateurs.
-C'était mon travail clinique
avec les réfugiés syriens,
et donc comment est-ce
qu'on travaille,
comment se fabriquent
des séances,
avec des gens qui sont vraiment...
Qui ont tout perdu,
j'allais dire.
-Michel Gurfinkiel,
vous avez
un livre en préparation
sur l'hébraïsme politique.
-Tout à fait, en effet.
L'hébraïsme politique
qui est ce phénomène
un peu oublié aujourd'hui
mais fondamental,
par lequel l'Europe
qu'on appelle moderne,
l'Europe du 16e siècle
au 18e siècle,
a essayé de résoudre
ses problèmes internes
en recourant non seulement
à la bible hébraïque
mais aussi, et c'est
tout à fait intéressant,
à la tradition juive,
à la tradition talmudique
et rabbinique.
C'est un phénomène qui a touché
les plus grands intellectuels
de cette époque.
-Merci, Michel Gurfinkiel,
ce qui vous fait plaisir.
-Bien sûr, on a enfin
traduit en France le livre de Nelson
sur "La République des Hébreux",
et le débat se lance
sur ce modèle moderne libéral
du 16e, 17e siècle,
et le retour à la bible hébraïque,
et à ce livre,
qu'on trouve même chez Bossuet,
finalement chez Rousseau,
et qui a inspiré sans doute
le modèle moderne politique,
mais qui avait disparu.
C'est intéressant, l'histoire
se réécrit toujours.
-Le titre
de votre livre ?
-Le mien, c'est autre chose,
c'est sur le judaïsme français,
"Jérusalem n'est pas perdue".
-C'est paru au Bord de l'eau.
-Oui, mais le livre de Nelson
est un très grand livre
par un grand professeur d'Harvard,
enfin en français.
-Il me reste à vous remercier
d'avoir participé à cette émission.
Il me reste à remercier
l'équipe de LCP, qui a permis
la réalisation de cette émission.
Et avant de vous quitter,
je voudrais vous laisser
avec cette citation,
vous me direz
si vous reconnaissez son auteur.
"Aujourd'hui, nous ne devons pas
nous masquer.
"Quand on parle de laïcité,
on ne parle pas vraiment de laïcité.
"On parle de gens qui,
au nom d'une religion,
"poursuivent un projet politique,
celui d'un islam politique
"qui veut faire sécession
"avec notre république."
Vous avez un nom ?
-Non.
-Et vous ?
C'est l'actuel président
de la République.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA